what up blog hope everyone's doing super
well this is a keynote that I gave in
Singapore that really struck there's a
bunch of stuff in management and running
operations a lot of my stuff is for
early entrepreneurs I think for
everybody who is running a business with
several employees or seven figures in
revenue are gonna get a lot of this one
so I hope you enjoy it and I'm really
excited to be here thank you so much
so we have a lot of time together which
is amazing and so I will take full
advantage of that and to be very honest
I want to get into the Q&A part and
start throwing this out to the you guys
to ask questions so I'm gonna try to get
to that as quickly as possible because I
think for me when I speak and what I
think has allowed me to have a nice
speaking career as I'm obsessed with
bringing as much value to the audience
as possible my origin story of Belarus
and lemonade stands at baseball cards is
something that you can see on YouTube
over and over and over again and as I
continue through my career of speaking I
want to do less of that and to be very
frank the reason I wrote a book called
askgaryvee is it's my great ambition to
build enough brand where I could come to
an environment like this and just go
right into QA because at the end of the
day I think that's where the biggest
value happens in a keynote and so what
I'll do because I'm gonna assume some of
you and many of you may not know who I
am I'll try to at least deliver on the
promise of giving a keynote but please
rest assure that I'm ready to go into
Q&A as soon as you guys are so look I
think the thing that regardless if
you're a b2b or b2c marketer regardless
if you're starting on your first day or
you've got a hundred million dollar
company I think the thing that will
really be important for us to chat about
first is the thing that we're all
connected by which is my obsession with
attention right before you can tell me
how great your product is or how katak
you are or why you're so right about
what you have to say to the world
whether as a purse
or as a business you have to get the
person's attention to tell your story to
me this is the most fascinating thing
that's happening right now in our
society is that attention has never been
more changing has never been harder to
grasp I think for a lot of us that have
been in business for a long time it's
very difficult to grab the current
changing landscape of attention at the
speed of which it changes I spend 8 10
12 15 hours a day trying to audit and
understand the tension and even for me
there's so many things still happening
that I haven't been able to completely
grab my hands on whether it's the depth
of East sports arbitrage as a cultural
phenomenon whether it's the blockchain
whether it's all the opportunity within
AI and m/l whether it's the emerging AR
infrastructure in the Apple updates and
Google infrastructure whether its voice
which I speak a lot about right now on
the Alexa Google and Apple fronts we are
talking about a very different world
than our grandparents and parents grew
up on as business men and women and more
importantly as marketers and executors
and most importantly as actual
practitioners of the craft I think the
thing that fascinates me the most is how
many people in here I mean to me when I
think about how many of you flew to be
here or here to see me speak we included
myself we're so much further ahead in
understanding these things because of
our interest in it regardless of your
success at this point in it if you're
sitting in this conference your
intuition or curiosity or execution
around the modern day attention graph
and the opportunities within it is so
much further accelerated than the 99%
and to me that's super interesting to me
that we have such an incredible
opportunity in front of us to trade on
this opportunity and so my question
becomes how much of what you believe in
know about this moment is around you
Reid
or consuming content and how much of it
is that you're actually executing within
it if I can do anything to start this
keynote off with if I can leave with
anything if I can impact you in any
shape or form to have one action item it
would be for you to start doing more of
the thing
let me explain there's a lot of people
in this room who understand the concept
of Kol Zoar Facebook Ads
but yet I don't think enough or actually
executing within those environments you
know if you know it's unbelievable how
many of you have opinions on these ad
products and platforms yet aren't
spending and executing yourself I think
the thing that I spend so much time on
is I produce content and do social media
because I want to stay a practitioner I
think of it as being a Mason or a
carpenter versus being an architect if
you look at that industry a lot of
architects grow up getting their hands
dirty and over time they get separated
too much from the work where they lose a
pulse on the reality of the current
infrastructure I'm fascinated by that
that is the thing that I try to stay
grounded in if I can get everybody here
to make one more ad to create one more
piece of content to a/b test six
different headlines on the same picture
in a facebook Instagram WeChat
environment these are very important
variables that not enough of us are
talking about and so at the most high
level I would hope to inspire people to
become practitioners instead of
pontificate errs in the craft of the
opportunity there's only one reason I
stand up here at this keynote and have
people want to hear what I have to say
it's because no matter what has been
happening to me I've not lost my pulse
on the craft of what I do how many
people here have been following me for
longer than a year so one more time
hands I just want to say
great almost all of you most of you 60
70 percent of you I'm a simple dude I
basically only believe in like 10 or 12
things and I pump out an obnoxious
amount of content which means that over
the course of a year you're gonna pretty
much grasp what my pillars are I think
the only thing that allows me the luxury
of keeping your attention over the long
haul is my ability to stay relevant to
where the opportunities are
the only reason after a year or two that
it's worth your time to give to me
versus something else it's because I've
had a good career for twenty years of
having enough intuition on what
consumers are gonna do but way more
importantly I don't talk about Alexis
skills and briefings I make an Alexis
skill in briefing so that I understand
it and and I would tell you there's a
huge lesson in that I think a lot of
people especially if they get in a level
of success start getting too far away
from the craft and you start building
around the raising the capital the
exiting of the company the writing of
the book you know the speaking on the
keynote like you just get away from the
work and I would argue that it's never
been more important to stay on top of
the work because every day it's changing
right to me I'm running late this
morning to our first meetings and I
quickly go on Instagram live because
they just created a new update where it
allows you to bring people into your
livestream that are watching you and I
did not feel comfortable being here
today without trying and tasting it and
understand the functionality in case one
of you asked me a question about it and
it's an important insight it's important
insight and it is the absolute
opportunity because when you think about
the way I think about it I talk about
day trading attention and when you talk
about day trading attention I'm not a
Wall Street guy I'm not a capitalist guy
but I understand the difference between
day trading and putting something into a
mutual fund and watching it grow
right there's a very different speed
there's a very different understanding
and that's how I think about it you know
my sign now says day trading attention a
year ago it used to say marketing in the
year that we live in why did I change it
from marketing in the year that you live
in to day trading attention it was
because I realized oh my god everything
we're about to talk about is happening
even faster that even if you believe in
something for that year within that year
it's changing too much influencer
marketing and Facebook and YouTube and
Twitter and line and we check this stuff
is changing too fast and we are not
keeping up with the subtle features
because if you really understand this
you know you look at something like
Instagram stories or Facebook watch or
all these subtleties in those little sub
arbitrage is polling in an Instagram
phone in those little features in those
little updates are oftentimes the
marginal opportunity that is the biggest
difference between growing your business
and not and so it's exhausting and it's
difficult but I have a one very
important statement around this for
everybody tough luck you know no matter
how we want it listen I wish that we
never evolved from email in 1996 I had
ninety percent open rates on my email
newsletter I was crushing it life was
good I had figured out email then in the
early 2000s I'd figured out Google
AdWords I wish that never changed I had
figured it out I won on that then
YouTube came out I had one of the first
long-form shows on YouTube in 2006 I
figured it out I liked it I wish Twitter
didn't come along but it did and then I
spent 15 hours a day tweeting all of you
and then I grew into one of the most
followed people on Twitter and then
Facebook evolved and like Instagram came
up and snapchat came like this is a
never ending game of attention
distribution and arbitrage and so I
think the biggest thing that you need to
understand is
the best product will always win if
people know about it right and so I
think the thing that I spend a lot of
time on is I'm a marketer I like to
market
I understand marketing I'm a business
builder I've built businesses I think
there's an incredible interesting kind
of graph between the quality of your
product and how many people know about
it so for example if you're a great
marketer and you listen to everything
that I say and you get a lot of
attention and your business isn't
working a lot of times it happens to do
with your product sucking you know like
we don't spend enough time talking about
the product or service you're selling
you know so please if you're sitting in
the audience and you're looking for the
magic pill or if you think that you're
gonna be able to siphon some information
that's gonna allow you to play in the
edges of the arbitrage of opportunity
please make sure you're looking at your
product and service to make sure it
delivers because if you follow my
blueprint if you get results from my
ideas that you then become an executor
of if your product sucks all that I'm
gonna do is expose your product faster
and you're gonna go out of business
faster so please start there but after
that please understand the following
this is a golden era of marketing for
one simple reason the places where our
attention and our consumers attention
are are now driven by marketplace
bidding dynamics not by writing an
upfront check to get the ads please
understand this please understand that
the biggest difference for us as
communicators is we don't need millions
of dollars to do television and print
and outdoor and direct mail to hit masse
we are trading on marketplaces Google
Facebook snapchat
these are biddable marketplaces the
reason this is the best time is because
those marketplaces are under priced
those marketplaces are under priced
right now because the biggest companies
in the world are not spending enough
money
you have to understand when there's a
come-to-jesus moment and the biggest
brands in the world properly spend in
everything that I talk about everything
I talk about becomes null and void when
you have to spend $48 CPMs to get in
front of potentially a thousand people
in a feed instead of $7 the mathematics
don't work out as nice for why I'm so
excited when influencers in Kol start
charging the proper price for their
product placement and endorsement it
won't be as fun of an opportunity and so
I continue to yell at the top of my
lungs right now how many people here
actually have been following me for
eight years
raise your hands there's not gonna be a
lot but just curious go a little higher
eight years first of all thank you for
the eight of you second of all second of
all you eight have a unique
understanding of me that many others
won't and let me explain for you eight
that I can see two of you right now that
you understand I was very loud Gary Vee
in 2009-2010 but then I got very quiet
for my standards in two thousand eleven
twelve thirteen and then I started
getting louder again in fourteen fifteen
fifteen sixteen seventeen right for
everybody else there's a reason I am my
most excited when I think there's an
arbitrage at scale if I had been making
content in 1996 I would have been
talking and making videos and audio and
written word about email until I put you
into nausea then I would have gotten
quiet in ninety nine because email had
caught up and then somewhere around 2001
I would have probably spent 24 months
yelling at you that this Google AdWords
thing is incredible intent marketing is
incredible if somebody searching to
drink wine that's probably good to buy
for five cents a click and I would have
yelled and screamed for two to three
years on Google Adwords and then
somewhere around 2006 seven incorrect
and the data data every single person in
this conference is going to regret not
spending more money on Facebook and
Instagram every single person in this
company I'm talking by the way I know
some of you have a b2b SAS business that
you haven't been able to figure out how
to do Facebook ads but I know tons of
b2b SAS businesses that are selling top
of the funnel and conversion based sales
every day on Facebook at scale because
they're trying harder than you to figure
out the creative that is the variable of
success please understand that the
creative is the absolute variable of
success that it may be the word or the
picture or the video that hasn't let you
be successful in Facebook not Facebook
and so I sit here with as you guys can
tell a different demeanor then sometimes
when I speak because I think it's very
serious
I think this is an enormous opportunity
and I very honestly I'm excited that I
know three of you are gonna email me in
four years and it's gonna be like Gary
you were right I didn't spend enough on
Facebook god damn it
so now that we've established that I
want to talk about the thing that
excites me the most right now which is
voice a lot of you have heard me yell
and scream about voice how many people
here have seen my enthusiasm for voice
raise your hands
great I'm awfully passionate about it
and I'm passionate about it because of
one of the more interesting chapters in
my career which is when I passed on uber
twice at a four million dollar valuation
in the angel round from one of my best
friends in the space the reason I passed
was first because it was a side project
for Garrett and Travis but second
because I didn't see it but why did I
invest a year later before it exploded
it was because I understood that uber
was selling time not
transportation and more importantly the
perception of time because if you've
ever been in New York City like me
there's nothing more humbling than
waiting for your uber and watching five
hundred cabs that are empty drive by you
now audio how many people here in the
last year have started spending more
time listening to my podcast and
watching less video because of it raise
your hands raise it high I want
everybody to look around this is the
insight that matters to me the most
right the the reason they've done that
is because what audio allow is that
video doesn't is passive consumption you
can listen to the podcast while doing
something else you can listen to the
podcast in a shower while you're driving
while you're working out it's time
arbitrage
audio will be a huge explosion for all
of us in every one of our businesses
because when you're communicating and
hopefully you're bringing value and not
running a radio commercial when you're
communicating and bringing value to your
audience and building awareness for
yourself you're gonna be doing it in a
way that respects their time the reason
I hate modern day advertising is it
because it steals time a pop-up banner
on your phone steals your time you have
to hit the X it's too small it pops up
it opens up you're pissed off you try to
exit and now you've wasted four seconds
which oh by the way means a lot to you
it would be stunning to you for you to
realize how much slower your internet
that you're used to in your office or
home has to be for you to feel it it's
staggeringly a little and so time only
with health and money and religion are
now on the pedestal of the things that
we care about the most and every
technology that I see that sells you
back time in exchange for your attention
will be the things that I bet on the
most and that is why I am
Oxley bullish on voice and when I say
voice I mean I think everybody here
should start a podcast I just do and in
the QA I'll show you an example of any
one of your businesses how it can be a
podcast if you'd like to ask me and - I
think everybody here should start
thinking about what it looks like to
develop a briefing or a skill inside of
Amazon Facebook excuse me Amazon Google
Apple whatever Facebook comes out with
whatever the tech giants from China come
out with it is going to be the way you
do search in the next five years five
years from today I promise you you will
be blown away by how much of your search
behavior is done with your voice as a
matter of fact one of the most
interesting stats that I'm paying
attention to is that one in every four
searches on Google on a mobile device is
done through voice and if you have young
children that play in a YouTube
environment on an iPad
they smite my son we was at three could
navigate the entire web through voice so
look my point here is very simple we are
ridiculously lucky because we get to
navigate through this time for anybody
over 30 and especially if you're over 40
you really recognize that because for
over 40 crowd here we lived free
internet in a lot of ways the scale is
remarkable the impact is high the upside
is enormous and to be very honest I
think most of us are just taking it for
granted I don't think we understand the
impact of how much the opportunity is
real and for me it becomes
disproportionately compounded because
you're actually at this conference
you're actually part part of a very
small interesting group for me which is
I know how big the opportunity is I know
that 99% of people have no idea it's
happening
you do so you're part of 1% of the whole
thing that understands it's happening
now it's yours to lose
I would argue that if you are not able
to achieve what you want to achieve in
life and you're at this conference
during this time then you really miss
executed then you really got into the
things that I worry about when I put out
content which is you worry way too much
about stuff that does not matter that
you're worried way too much about other
people's opinions which is the biggest
reason you don't take chances because
you worry about how people judge your
failures then then you're doing a lot of
other things that are leading to huge
levels of miss shots and missed
opportunities and so that's why I speak
so much about being insular having the
right intent because literally
fundamentally if you synthesize
everything I've just said non-action is
the fundamental reason that most of you
will fail at this point being in this
room at this conference during this time
and understanding quite a bit of what's
actually happening non-action which if
you take all the way to the seed of a
human being is insecurity which is
probably the biggest reason that I
create content because I hope that you
use me as your shield to do [ __ ] period
so that's what I think is happening
audios super interesting to me feat
dynamics and a mobile device are the
currency today it will continue to be
for a little while
enormous things are happening around us
on blockchain and AR and things that
nature they're all coming they're all
circling around some things are much
further away than people realize I am
very very anti consumer VR in the short
term if you asked me this great
phenomenon that I'm so obsessed with
called the Internet
the only thing that
arbitrage trashes it out is VR if we
live in a full VR world than now what
right cool but nobody here knows a
single human being that spends an hour
in VR in a week
not for non-business purposes consumer
behaviors not they're my friends for the
people that are the smartest when it
comes to tech in here the biggest thing
that stops you from being successful is
you understand that the tech is ready
but you haven't factored in consumer
behavior the biggest reason that so many
super smart technologists fail with
their products is they anticipate text
and they understand that it works
there's so many things that work right
now that are four seven nine years away
because we're not ready to use it that
way online dating worked in 1996 but it
took another decade before there was a
stigma removed from it that allowed it
to start having some legs and ten years
after that
now it's mainstream right that is
basically what I do for a living day
trading attention understanding behavior
around it what are people going to do
today that's meaningful to the goals
that we have a couple things that I want
to throw out before we go into QA one
thing that has come up quite a bit today
since I've been doing interviews and
interacting with people on social here
in Singapore is because I have a
personal brand which oh by the way is
such an interesting word because it gets
people very emotional in both directions
I just want to remind people that hate
people with personal brands it's just a
slang term for your reputation so people
that have a reputation or a personal
brand there's a lot of people asking me
if that's a requirement to build a
successful business and I find that
laughable because I want to remind
everybody I want to remind everybody
that 99% of businesses don't have a
personal brand in front of them you know
I think that it's a great
have I think if you are charismatic or
narcissistic or enjoy the attention it's
a nice to have I super love it I love
taking selfies with you as much as you
love taking it with me it brings
awareness it's branding but it is far
from the reason why one would be
successful and it's definitely not a
requirement to be successful in today's
business environment the acquire the
requirement to be successful is very
simple is your product good enough and
do people know about it and you have the
structure to get people to know about it
better than the people you compete with
for the same share of attention and
money for that product it's very very
very very basic the biggest issue is
slash opportunity is the speed in which
it turns and changes and so a couple of
the things I want to talk about let's
make a contextual to this audience I
want to remind most of you that you have
a disproportionate advantage from most
entrepreneurs in the US which is
oftentimes not always because of
cultural differences but oftentimes you
get to see a preview of what's happening
before it happened when I think about my
friends that have built successful
businesses in Southeast Asia by simply
paying attention of what's happening in
America and then replicating some
version of it in the market it is
literally the dream come true you know
American entrepreneurs got mad at those
brothers in Germany right who would rip
off the ideas and build a business I
always was so upset about that I mean I
think Facebook has proven that there's
no ripping off if it's a feature and I
think I would also argue that ripping
off by looking at a different business
in a different market and then
interpreting it into your market is far
from ripping off I think it's called
smart so I would highly recommend
it's pride which I think holds back a
lot of people but please take advantage
for the disadvantages one could think
they have there's only 5 million here if
you want to do it in Din Denisha if
there's a lot of people but there's so
many microclimates so that's you know so
many different segmentations mainly in
China
whatever you would deem a disadvantage
please understand you have the greatest
advantage which is 90% of things are
human not cultural 90% of things are
human not cultural if you're capable of
understanding the culture of your
consumer and layer the cultural context
on top of the human thing that is
happening in America you are halfway
home an unbelievable advantage to be an
entrepreneur in this region and watch
things play out by the way for free no
report needed no hiring Boston
Consulting or bein a McKinsey by reading
and watching videos and downloading apps
something that I don't believe most
people in this conference are taking
full advantage of or respecting enough
of how big of an advantage that is and
to me very honestly I'm quite selfish
when I speak I dream in three years from
now you email me nothing would make me
happier than getting an email from
somebody here who said they had a 50
million dollar exit because you know
they just looked at what was working in
America and they built the replica ish
of it here please do that
please understand how big of a deal that
is and I would argue it is your singular
biggest advantage in this market to be
able to be shown what will work and then
allow you to interpret it oftentimes
with very little change in the model
cool
cool what else is interesting to me um
you know what's super interesting to me
LinkedIn let me talk about LinkedIn for
a second how many people here are on
LinkedIn
good this will work LinkedIn's
interesting to me
I think LinkedIn is up to something
that I think will be beneficial for a
lot of us first of all how many people
are in b2b marketing raise your hands
so look raise them higher because I see
a lot of half-ass hands higher great two
hands nice b2b I've said this before
I'll say it again because I'm not sure
how many have heard it here's how I
think about b2b marketing in every one
of our b2b spaces there's usually a
magazine or two that is the leading b2b
magazine in our sector right there just
a b2b magazine that our customers read I
think that's the thing that you should
attack I think you as a company and a
service should look at the b2b magazine
and deem that your competitor more than
people you compete with to sell
contracts to clients let me explain it
is my belief that everybody in here is
no longer an advertiser but that
everybody in here is a media company so
I know a lot of you have heard me say
don't listen to what I'm saying watch
what I'm doing
I don't advertise I act like a media
company and then from that I have top of
the funnel brand awareness that leads to
my business I don't buy ads on a Dage I
don't sponsor things that can I produce
content with my points of view act like
a media company and they funnel into an
environment where I've built 125 million
dollars in revenue and AD world without
winning a single RFP right so I don't
know what all of you do in your b2b
business but I would look at why people
read the b2b magazine and I would argue
that you need to start becoming a media
company for the sector and then trading
off of the top of the funnel awareness
let me explain again in 2006 this
happened to me intuitively I started a
wine show on YouTube less than a year
after YouTube was launched I thought
that I was gonna make infomercials I
thought my main plan when there was a
camera like that in my office for
episode 1 was I was gonna sit there and
sell you wine something very interesting
happened if you want to go on youtube
and watch episode 1 of Wine Library TV
somewhere in the first three minutes you
can even see my face take a little weird
turn you could see me thinking because I
realized that this would never go away
that this video would live forever and I
realized that if I was shilling wine
that I didn't believe in that I could be
exposed so somewhere within the first
three minutes of me ever producing a
piece of content for the internet in my
life I switched from being a Salesman to
being a media company I would argue that
most of the behavior in the way that you
produce content has short-term sales DNA
versus long-term media DNA and this is
the vulnerability of why you're not
getting the returns that you're looking
for from this environment so I would
please implore a lot of you to realize
that I believe one of the first hires of
your business in the future
is your editor-in-chief of your business
an actual media editor for a SAS product
or a consultancy firm or whatever you do
and so this media mindset is super
fascinating let me explain it in an even
more historical nature do you guys know
that the michelin tire company in the
early 1900s decided to start writing
reviews of hotels and restaurants in the
countryside's of europe because people
weren't driving enough and using up the
tires and stopping in their gas stations
so they started reviewing restaurants
and inns positively if they were further
away from London in Paris to get the
wealthy to drive out there and stop by
their stations and use up their tires
and that is why we to this day
have restaurants rated three stars
Michelin because the Michelin tire
company a hundred years ago executed on
my thesis in the same vain Guinness beer
company after declining in pubs for the
first time around the same time realized
that a lot of people were talking about
trivia at the bar and literally created
the Guinness Book of World Records to
get you to talk about crazy records and
trivia in a pub and used the word
Guinness so that you would
subconsciously reorder a Guinness in the
pub this is super interesting to me I'm
a very big believer that the future has
all of its seeds in the past and so I
implore all of you to become much better
historians around how to use media as a
top of the funnel gateway to sales
around your business once you understand
that you will find far more success in
LinkedIn if you write a white paper that
helps lawyers run their business and
then it's a gateway drug to what you
sell them then if you were to try to
just sell them an ad saying free
consultation if you use my firm media
DNA versus advertising DNA media again
you want distribution and retail stores
write a white paper on LinkedIn 15
things that retailers need to do in 2018
brought to you by your brand I promise
you you will be stunned by how much
inbound opportunity you have in that
environment media not advertising so
those are some of the top of the funnel
things that are really on my mind I
continue to execute I continue to do I'm
I'm very fascinated by how much time
people spend dwelling
and debating I think we glorify strategy
and we underestimate execution I feel
like if you look historically and rewind
the biggest successes the strategy came
from the execution and you did some
Monday Morning Quarterback I'm a real
genius in hindsight because I can
manipulate how I got there after the
fact I'm gonna talk about so many things
in different ways than the intent that
was at first because you don't even
realize that your strategy came from it
because when you're doing the strategies
happening in real time you almost forget
why you were doing it in the first place
and so I promise you indecisiveness and
debate and pontificating and ultimately
ego is stopping so many people from
being successful and while I'm on that
how many people have more than 10
employees raise your hand great I think
it's worth bringing up hiring I'm super
passionate about hiring how many people
have more than 10 employees raise your
hands I think one of the biggest flaws
in most of your companies is your own
ego wrapped up in being somebody that's
good at hiring I want to tell this story
because I think it's one of the most
fascinating things happening in small
businesses I'm stunned by how many small
businesses CEOs founders or owners think
they're good at hiring and have made
this a thing they've made it a thing
because they wrap their pride in hiring
and here's what happens I feel like my
EQ and people's skills are off the
charts I am baffled by how many horrible
hires I've made in the last 20 years a
lot so when I think about my intuition
and ability and process and deploy that
against the masses I know a lot of you
have made huge amounts of mistakes
hiring I so don't give a crap what you
think about me then I'm very comfortable
and excited about admitting that I was
wrong and firing very
Clee most people sit on people for a
year or two because they don't want to
be exposed at making a wrong decision
and in that time enormous amounts of bad
stuff happens to your business so in a
completely random thing from what I've
been talking about if I can get one
person here to fire the person they
should be firing in their business right
now after today I will feel very
accomplished on my entire trip to
Singapore who's got a question great you
see that that was good accuracy what's
your name Melvin Melvin yeah and first
up I would want to say Gary thank you so
much because of what you did you changed
my life if you remember uh slightly
earlier this year you started a contest
20:17 flip challenge know that GV g v--
podcast contest yes yes so at the point
I'm almost in the US and I knew that by
the time that that thing's gonna happen
I will be in New Jersey New York so I
was hustling really hard to get you to
pay attention to me obviously it didn't
happen yes yeah alright but but the good
part was that what I did was I did
exactly what you told me to do or what
you have been saying so I I had the hash
tag I started tweeting everyone who who
who submitted that entry and I said
congratulations I asked them this is my
favorite Gary we caught what's yours and
then I started getting reply and so that
was when when I got the reply and that
was when I restarted my vlogging journey
again so this is the third time I
started my vlogging journey so this time
when I started my vlogging journey boom
it happened people started paying
attention I think your you know him
Chris Brogan pay attention to me he he
tweeted out my video
you know he even jam on a call with me
to do an interview so that was great
that's awesome yeah so yeah so so phrase
up I like to thank you for for ignoring
me because if you if you haven't ignored
me you know I wouldn't have thought of
that I love it yeah
so that's one now number two is that I
think there are three things that we
have in common
number one we are the same favorite
number found number number two we have
this we're born in the same month nice
to me
yeah all right so so so the other thing
is I want to say is that when I started
my vlogging again this done this time
around her time I started getting
attention yeah and I started getting
discovered and now cop is stuck calling
me people stop calling me and say that
can you do videos for me so now I'm here
today and I'm devastated why because
you're talking about audio all right yes
so my question is right now I'm
beginning to crush it if you notice
actually I said to you earlier on
Twitter that I'm not coming in because
I'm executed on what you say and I'm
crushing it - no time but I'm here today
because I want to see you I want to say
thank you to you thank you and and so my
question to you it's basically this for
someone who is really getting traction
in terms of video people started paying
attention both would yeah yeah I know
but would I be would I be so what would
the strategy be both what would the
strategy be what would I do with
podcasts I don't know
okay but let's talk about it first the
answer is both okay oh yeah now let me
rephrase it depends on your ambition
okay first of all I love going deep on
what works
just because audios rising doesn't mean
videos dead yeah you know it's so funny
we've been the same for a very long time
we as humans consume content in written
form in audio and NVIDIA yep
whether it's TV newspaper or radio or
blogs podcasts and YouTube it's the same
game so nothing's gonna die if you have
real ambition to build a personal brand
that you want to arbitrage opportunities
on my answer is both because in 16 hours
you can get a lot done you know people
always say to me do you sleep and this
and that Gary's always pushing no sleep
Isle I mean if you follow me carefully I
talk about six seven eight hour sleep
I'm not worried about you sleeping I'm
worried about what you're doing when
you're awake sixteen hours is a lot of
time to do damage and so you know what
would you do on your podcast I you know
look what I did at first I believed an
audio about a year and a half ago I
wanted to get in I was busy I didn't
have the infrastructure I have now so
what did I do
I transcribed the askgaryvee video show
into audio yeah right then I watched it
it wasn't enough value add and it was
made for video so it wasn't contextual
to audio so my podcast was not doing as
well as it could then on vacation where
I ended a little time to think I decided
to rebrand it to the Gary Vee audio
experience which gave me a lot more
flexibility to give you guys original
content that you didn't hear anywhere
else keynotes different things and it
took off you know you have to look at
yourself of what you're capable of doing
especially when you're one-man band and
I don't know if you have anybody helping
you yet so as a one-man band what I
would do is if you're vlogging every day
I would take ten minutes of something
that you're doing or talking about not
show it in video form rip the audio
make that your podcast got it thank you
you're welcome back here can you pass it
on to the next question question your
aim is not we're we're the same yeah hi
Gary how are you my name is Kenneth how
are you oh I'm very good very good how
about you super good to see you here I
would like to say a big thank you to you
although I did not follow you for years
but in the past six months a lot of
things have changed I'm writing a book
I use comedy that's released and in fact
email you I guess I have not has so
enough to email you a lot of times but
because of that of you ignoring again I
realized that I need to do something and
I took the action of document versus
create because for me I'm a marketer
marketing consultant I always think of
crazy ideas but I never go into document
yet so what I did is because of my book
matter that's released
I interviewed 15 monthly notes that I
put into my book that I personally know
and because moms love to share they
start referring mum Adam and pronounce
but I could not put them into the book
and that's where I created my facebook
life with me every Monday and I
documented documenting and I interviewed
them and it's growing and growing so my
question to you is how should I bring it
scale it up from there and I am
personally I own a creative marketing
company so how do I put it together so
you want to figure out how to use the
leverage of the ship the weekly show to
build on top of yep what would you like
to happen
would you like to it to be a gateway
drug to your creative shop do you want
to build a SAS product for mompreneurs
or do you want to become a personal
brand and live as being the human that
makes enough dollars I think you have a
lot of flexibility of what you can do
yeah but this is where you have to start
backwards so for me the reason I think
I'm winning is for me backwards I'm more
interested in my legacy than making
money which is why all of you like me
because I'm trying to win you over by
giving
you value not get a short-term sale
which is why it's building legacy so all
my behaviors work backwards I just gave
you in one second three viable options
on the back of this do you have an
answer you have a clear answer to that
or is that something you need to debate
I because there's a lot of options that
I could do which I'm working on but is
not coming back to me as fast because
how long have you been alive show
episode 15 so I'm going for my 16 on
doing on a weekly basis huh one five one
five years yes I just added yeah so
because of death yeah so I'm going on
and on I'm not stopping and it's growing
and it's not just locally it's also into
u.s. and the law of attraction people
start referring it's called Facebook yes
yep so I'm continuing that and getting a
lot of traction getting partners are
coming and also to sponsor for my book
so that's why I'm working towards and I
also like what you have mentioned is to
put it as a media so I'm also
abstracting partners our companies to
come in - maybe like mompreneurs they
have their own business can I give you a
good piece advice that's good for
everybody yeah the sooner you monetize
the quicker you give up the leverage the
question is how to monetize yeah I
understand
so and the answer is I really wish you
didn't give a [ __ ] about monetizing just
yet so you know there's a lot of ways to
monetize you just rattled off several
and I rattled off several hmm so I don't
think I don't think you haven't are you
having a are you having trouble closing
the opportunities I guess this draaga is
because I want to bring up value I want
to push this mom for a new movement all
around and to drive this rather than
focusing on monetizing but monetizing is
still our bread and butter that's why
but they're very different things right
like one of the things that really works
for me is I don't want to monetize any
of you I have an agency that works with
the top 100
brands right so couldn't you monetize
with what you're doing and continue to
build equity with the mom preneur
community I could do that just that I
have to speed up and also though I speed
up dude you've done 15 episodes you're
four seconds in
what do you try where are you going
what's the rush get it I mean that's the
punchline Yeah right yeah do you think
it's gonna go away do you think you
found some sort of rare you know pot at
the end of the rainbow that's gonna
disappear I'm asking a few days unique
coming from a man coming from with that
interviewing mom who knows so what he's
scared about a bunch of dudes here
trying to talk to the mom preneur 'he's
no yeah so i guess it's to find out you
know to find out what because I have my
own creative marketing company it's like
like what you've been doing the in
Armenia you're doing your your business
at the same time I feel that being
author writing my book interviewing
mompreneurs it's kind of like my
Superman time I get to do all this thing
which I love to do it by the same time I
have to be Clark Kent I have to do all
the work and get my abuse pain and all
that which is my problem is you can't
monetize Superman to be Superman yep you
followed yes that's the problem you're
trying to sell a logo on Superman suit
and it's gonna look really stupid you
following or no yeah I get it
the answer is you don't monetize it mmm
got it thanks because because two things
will happen
one you're still gonna monetize this
Clark Kent mmm I spent you know how I
don't you watch TV at all yeah yeah you
know how I always talk about like you're
not seeing any of it yeah cuz you're not
13 hours a day that you see nothing of
me and meetings with clients sometimes
I'll do a fast music and B just to show
you just to remind you I'm actually
doing but
I don't think it's super fun content and
I think it's a waste of your time to
watch me and b-roll be in 11 hours of
meetings you know I'm very good at being
Clark Kent and I have no interest in
monetizing Superman you're trying to
monetize Superman which is going to be
the undoing of both hey hi Gary my name
is Raju how are you very pleased to be
here and also I need to start by saying
big thank you because I've been
following you for about one year maybe
thank you but really needed some of
those principles maybe I read too many
[ __ ] stories of get rich overnight
and kind of I was having that illusion
in my brain that it's supposed to be
fast and I think the top thing that I
took from you is that look it takes time
yeah it's really interesting right
because my personality and I'm sure some
of you felt this the first time you saw
me my personality seems so [ __ ] yes
and it's ended up being my biggest
strength because I have that kind of
pizzazz that all the [ __ ] people
that say it's gonna happen fast have I'm
able to get your attention and then I
trick you into going slow yeah and then
you actually get what you want yeah it
works so thank you very much for that my
question is and now I'll work through it
was I'm not sure I have it clearly in my
head so basically I've been doing head
hunting and human resources executive
search for about four years I like it
very specific to a field which is supply
chain and logistics I like that too I
started a podcast about two three months
ago which is going really well that
makes sense cause leaders in supply
chain so I'm trying to do let me tell
you why I think that notice how I said
that makes sense super narrow you know
what's so funny it's how I think about
Singapore I think having five million
citizens is the advantage not the
disadvantage
everybody's so quick to build here and
then go and do Indonesia and other parts
that you forget that
if you win the entire five million
market you have a real business
I love podcasts in in very narrow supply
chain are you kidding nobody everybody
thinks they have to make like consumer
the meanwhile is if you get the right
800 people listening to your 800 if you
get the right 800 people listening to
your podcast you're headhunting
businesses gonna explode yeah it's it's
starting well I guess it's just the so I
think it will need a little bit more
time but it's happening because I'm
engaging with really c-level people that
because it's also creating that platform
that this industry doesn't have
correctly it also is media so your
ability to email somebody who's the
decision-maker at a company to be a
guest who nobody would ask to be a guest
of anything and now they become aware of
what you do on the side yeah give
Superman away for free watch Clark Kent
make money yeah so I guess all of this
is happening I think it needs still a
bit of time a lot more time of course
where I guess where I'm I'm kind of
struggling over I guess where my
question is so on one side we are
selling headhunting so basically you
recruit the best for your business which
is HR then on the other side I'm
specialists in an industry which is
logistics supply chain so then I'm kind
of because sometimes also people
especially if it's very senior level so
I've engaged with with some board levels
but I went on the side of the podcast to
them and then they they don't
necessarily remember if they remember
okay that's the podcast guide they don't
remember you as the headhunting guy yeah
so I during the podcast I do the bit on
on the industry I do the bit on the HR
how do you recruit your people and I try
to make that connection so I guess where
I'm struggling with and I don't know
what's the best way moving forward I
think it was gonna work if I keep it to
supply chain and logistics I'm also
considering should I keep it to Asia so
expand it and say saying doing business
in Asia right and make it a little bit
broader
I mean you mean the shell yeah and also
the business but I can also I can then
flip the the headhunting business to
expand as well do you feel like your
business is ready to do that
I don't know yeah I feel like it isn't
there probably longer right this is you
see what's happening right it's the same
reason you like to get quick fast it's
his question guys it's the same [ __ ]
it's everybody like it's the same game
over and over and over I get it and even
when you have some level of success it's
hard I get it I get it I live it I have
way more opportunity than you could ever
wrap your head around but I stay
disciplined on what I can do why didn't
we've been registered to do business in
Singapore for three years why is
vaynermedia not here we weren't ready
was my brand ready yes would we get
business yes would it deliver at the
level that I thought I needed to to
create 20 year success no you're on to
something and this is what happens to a
lot of businesses I look at it every day
you're on to something and now you're
tasting blood in the water and you're
getting greedy because you see it and
especially if you're hearing it for
something like this you're like wait a
minute this is gonna you know like
you're compounding your confidence which
is making you go wide when you should be
going deeper thank you welcome
[Applause]
hello hi Gary my room is a Mashhad and
like what you said 80% of your content
today is more or less in youtube i said
20% i kind of absorb i should connect to
this box for my mom but firstly i want
to tell you I'm actually going to quit
my job to do something like d-roc for a
word-of-mouth marketing company but
before I pass this on to my mom is that
you're due case with shoes that's my
question
these are my new cases shoes all right
awesome also awesome thanks hi Gary I'm
camellia Hickman my son got me on to you
I didn't even know you are you around
thanks a lot well I am good news 99% of
people don't so go ahead it's okay
they're the word is getting around they
will right I'm a warm ologist and a lot
of people ask me what I do I'm actually
a specialist in would amount of
marketing Bournemouth would amount
offline yes because I'm not an online
person I've never been and but he's
gonna get me on it because of you okay
so thank you for that
thank you but what you call it it has
always been a stigma that for many
entrepreneurs that word of mouth
marketing is a very weak activity and
yet a lot of what I call it material
says that it is the most powerful form
of marketing and I took it on for the
last four years I did research I started
a business group for it and I found out
why it was most the most powerful but my
question to you would be where do you
see it in the next three to five years
how does how would it grow how would it
evolve with a mouth marketing in the
market especially for entrepreneurs so
word-of-mouth marketing is what social
media is right all that social media is
is the plumbing and infrastructure that
has created word-of-mouth marketing to
hit the scale that it's always had in
the invisible nature of the
conversations that we have with each
other in real life
so like even in my first book that put
me on to the world crush it that I wrote
in 2008 most of it refers to word of
mouth and in the book I wrote in 2011
Thank You economy is basically just
about word-of-mouth marketing
it's about being extraordinary to force
word-of-mouth marketing I'm I believe
nothing sells product and services more
than another human being to another
human being right where it lives I think
will continue to go into this device
social media not us talking and I think
that's great
I think too many people want us to talk
to each other so I find platforms
fascinating I find it fascinating that
we put a pen and paper somebody writing
a letter today as this incredibly great
gesture okay even though we do it on
here all the time we're putting pen and
paper on a pedestal not the words that
were exchanging with each other and so I
think word-of-mouth marketing is
basically the old-school term for social
media I'm a buyer to the end of time
until the robots kill us I'm a fan nice
pass how are you um how are you okay I
have this question okay
first of all um I've been following you
for a few years now I think back from
2014 and you completely changed my life
and how I operated my business it was
really tiny back then but we managed to
have like really healthy growth it year
after year thanks to you thank you
thanks to you and the question is we're
at a point where we're in that crossroad
where we have to decide where
we want to either grow organically yes
or we have the we also have the
opportunity to grow rapidly as well
because we have interests and if you
grow rapidly you have to take investment
yeah because we have interested by this
wanting to offer that to us as well and
do you own the business yes 100% so
that's the thing I'm I just wanted to
hear you're taking that like if you have
opportunity to grow do you own the
business 100% yes do you want to have a
boss it depends it depends on the end
goal because I do have a certain angle
that I want to get to so I'm just I just
wanted to hear your take in terms of do
you how do you feel about growing
consistently organically on your own but
it'll take really long time and somebody
else might come in and take away the
opportunity and do you believe that
you'll never know like I feel like I
have a certain value to offer and
there's nothing like it at this point so
I feel like I have that certain value
and I have that following I have the the
trust and the loyal of our customers as
well if you can raise capital to speed
up your process yeah and to create
bigger distance between somebody copying
you that's meaningful and you don't give
up control okay it's a worthwhile debate
okay eighty percent of a hundred million
is better than a hundred percent of
forty million from a dollar standpoint
okay just don't think that just because
you sold off twenty percent of your
company doesn't mean that you're not
going to be held accountable let me give
you an example when AJ and I sold a
piece of vaynermedia to Steven Ross one
of the things that I made required is
that I never had to have a meeting to
tell them how the business was doing all
right he liked that it's a good one
right now he was worth eight billion
dollars so he could give a crap pass you
need to make sure whether you sell one
person you could sell one
of your company and that investor might
take up a disproportionate amount of
your time okay the biggest issue is time
when you sell a piece of your company
yeah do you really want to prep for an
entire week every 90 days for an
investor meeting so you can justify your
behavior yeah but the thing is um I'm
quite keen on taking that offer because
it's much more of a strategic
partnership that will bring of value to
me so let's talk about that for a minute
yeah is it a human or is it a company
both because the company is the human
that you're excited about being a
strategic value prop to you an employee
of the company or owns the company wins
the company okay so you feel you'll get
value from this individual yeah both
side because they wanted to invest
because they wanted to have us under
their portfolio as well sure why that
could bring a certain value to them as
well so that's why they wanted of course
yeah how I mean you know as you can see
as we're digging yeah there's no right
answer to this all right
I think the question becomes how
comfortable you feel with them yet I
think you need to make sure you
over-talk expectations all right young
entrepreneurs often make the mistake of
only seeing the good side of an
investment yeah and there's you know
nobody's giving you lots of money
because they think you're awesome
yeah and so you just need to be
thoughtful the amount of people that
I've seen raise capital when they didn't
need to and it destroyed their business
is more than I'd like to say yeah at the
same token there's a ton of people who
would have failed and gone out of
business without a strategic investment
and then it turned into a huge success
here's what I would say everything
that's in your stomach that you want to
ask and talk about do it before you sign
that contract that's the mistake you sit
on two or three things that you just
think will work themselves out bring
them to the forefront okay makes sense
yeah I'm sure there's one to two things
that are in your head
like you were saying there's no right or
wrong it's just I have a certain angle
that I wanted to get to and Buddhist
angle me the our amount no no no it's in
terms of the the impact of the company
that I wanted to because the kind of
invite I wanted to get that if I wanted
to have that certain impact the level
that I wanted to have it I need a
partner and that's what I can ask you a
question yeah
the impact that you want the company to
have could you get to that impact 11
years from now yeah so then you have to
ask yourself are you trying to get to
the impact sooner and you're putting
that as a romantic point of view in your
head and are you giving up too much to
get there sooner because it's just one
bigger version of patience this is why
I'm pounding patients down people's
throats and more importantly is this
impact real or is it manifested in your
head as a romantic thing you know you
got to think about those things
yeah no it's real because the thing with
our company you were super engaged
because customers and our followers they
don't see us as a branch they see us as
a friend okay so that's how we built
like be careful because at scale that
tends to go when I get that yeah that's
the thing we have to have a certain
balance somewhat yeah that was probably
the thing that scared me the most
because if that's how your consumers
feel yeah it's almost impossible for
somebody investing in you to being
comfortable with you doing the behavior
that makes that a hundred percent pure
they are thinking about the scale of
that which then dilutes the energy of
that yeah it's not my voice is the
company's voice so they don't see the
brand as a person it's just yeah yeah
they see the like the people that runs
this company has a system value that
they resonate to linnaeus one last
question and we'll move on does the
investor have any say after a
transaction
no not really good do it alright but but
just make sure you define the not really
part yeah because no because they do
have a certain they based on the
conversations that we have they do
wanted to offer advice try to bring up a
certain value for us but at the everyday
ultimately is still my decision because
that's what they did should yeah did we
lose it
oh yeah hi Gary how are you I'm good I'm
good how I sell okay I'm Shawn I'm a
digital marketer from Malaysia first off
I took your advice and I started
blogging not too long ago and I am
already seeing work doors that I could
never imagine I was I need to open for
me and I only have you to thank you for
that I have a two-part question yes
first my father owns a traditional
billboard business with about 1,000
sites mostly along the highway and
persuading him to invest into digitally
I don't I don't work for his business
yet by assume I will in the future given
your expertise if we became partners
today in this business how would you
focus your resources and what would you
what what your forceps be what kind of
business is it tried to show billboard
business what billboard billboard yeah
so your dad owns billboards yes 1000
sites along the highway which is rad is
it art a digital no it's so I would
probably make the capital invest if I
took over my dad's business or became
his partner I'd probably take the
capital risk up front to take them
digital because I think that's gonna be
required to get the value out of that
outdoor right I would also look to
diversify because I'd be too fearful
you're young dude I'm too fearful about
self-driving cars and all the things
that happen over the next 20 30 years
that would disproportionately decrease
the value
the asset that you have right so my
intuition is that I would diversify I
would either sell off half the board's
and then put it into building a media
company or I would reinvest all the
profits each year into building some
sort of digital complement to a
traditional product like that okay got
it the second part of the question is as
an accent extension to my blogging I
plan to start a series of interview
videos or podcast sessions with people
within the same view to talk to to talk
about the work they do and I was
wondering this is a trying my luck here
would you be my first guest to officiate
this so I won't but I'll share heads but
if you do 15 episodes I'll be your 16th
ok I already have 22 what's that I
started my blog like 22 episodes but
I'll start 15 interviews after after
that and you'll be much you've done 22
vlog episodes logs but if I was
listening carefully you asked me to be a
guest on your new podcast all right okay
so that I'll wait until on the 16th got
it thank you very much you're welcome
[Music]
hello hello yeah hi Gary my name is
Terence and I'm 20 this year so just one
question for you I've been listening to
you for about a year now and I'm just
trying to figure out as a 20 year
without any experience in my parents
business I've wanted to build a video
blog and audio podcast but I have the
experience to actually do it so which
answer should I focus on building up the
experience in the business or should I
go down to help market it well listening
if you if you started a podcast at a
video blog about being experienced in
the craft that would be bad faking it
but if your podcast was about the
experience of learning the craft you'd
probably have a lot of 20 year olds
following you okay so I don't think it's
about getting the experience
when I talk about I built a business for
15 years before I came out right I say
that because that's what happened but I
have a funny feeling if the internet was
around when I was a kid like this I
might have started documenting my
journey right away I just wouldn't be
walking around like I was a business
building guy I would be talking about
being a young ambitious guy who used to
sell baseball cards and now I'm about to
do it for wine and I would take people
along with my journey that's my biggest
problem with people that don't have
experience they're lying they're lying
that they're business experts or my
favorite you're a 20 year old life coach
because you know you've lived life so so
to me I think you can start the podcast
and the video blog I mean I wish I did
that because I there was I probably
cried cried 50 times in the first 10
years that I worked with my dad because
they were very painful fights and that
would have been incredible content that
I wish you guys could watch if you're in
a family business because it turned out
ok and it would have been really cool to
see how that happened and why and how I
was able to give more than I took and
how I loved my dad more than the money
and how I thought about what I could do
in my 30s and 40s and it's ok to lose in
my 20s but I wouldn't have walked around
and said I was a marketing genius
because I thought I was gonna be yeah so
start documenting my journey to becoming
a business man hell yeah
got it if you think that's interesting
maybe you maybe you're not comfortable
enough in your own skin to talk about
all the failures which is the most
interesting part of documenting being a
20 year old business man but if you are
there's some people that are gonna
listen the truth always wins my friend
that's all you need to know
can I get a Hut a hug yeah sure
awesome are we gonna take a picture of
the hug he's a liar he said he was gonna
do a hug and now he's doing a blob all
right after this question let's send it
over there because they're about to
start a coup go ahead I thank you Gary
and I flew in I flew in from Malaysia to
see you thank you okay so okay I'm a
little bit of confused right now you
know business because we're in the
hosting business hosting yes hosting
website not only website right but CBS
team understood yes so when we are
saying because Google Amazon IBM all the
big giant idea yes and when you are
saying marketing budget we can't compete
and no way come for the content the
blog's the video they're everywhere
so do you have any advice for who's
using you now okay what we do how many
customers do you have okay about 500 ok
great so we have a great situation here
yeah the first thing if I was your new
partner okay and I was brought in to do
the marketing as the partner the first
thing I would do is figure out why those
500 people are using us and then that
would be the content that I would
distribute okay don't ever mistake money
as a competitive advantage because
plenty of big companies throw money
directly in the trash mm-hm
so there's a reason 500 people are using
you now it may be that you're very good
at dr and intent based marketing and
you're winning on Google AdWords I don't
know
then that after I figure out why you
have 500 customers then I would ask you
next question which is how long have you
been in business about five years great
and how many customers do you have that
have been with you for three years or
more I do not have the exact numbers but
I guess is somewhere about 50 great then
I would survey them and listen they may
stay with you because it's passive once
you're on a server you don't want to
mess it but I would look for the insight
is it the homegrown you know high-touch
small I don't know but once I understood
why people were coming to us and staying
with us I would make all my
communication around that I'm never
worried about who's got more money when
I had a liquor store doing 3 million
dollars a year 10% gross profit 300,000
before expenses my marketing budget in
year one was $14,000 for the year and
wine.com the first version raised a
hundred thirty million dollars the
amount of days that I spent worrying
about them was this [ __ ] Google okay so
your suggestion is went well I'm going
to look into the insights and the next
step is to content marketing is it
content always so are you doing
conversion base like is that how you're
getting your customers okay we are just
rank all connect ly yes go and recently
we started blogging yes yeah so that's
what we are only doing as a little bit
of Google Earth and Facebook marketing
but they don't really works well yes
have you done Facebook ads against
employees of companies that you want to
get on sorry I don't get it
when you run a Facebook ad you have to
target it yes it's not putting a piece
of content and hitting boost
that's 17 years ago it's making a piece
of content and targeting who you want to
reach
or do you do the marketing um yes III
I'm getting it yeah so when you've done
Facebook you said it doesn't work for
you when you post it are you running ads
against the content no we do it directly
to the landing page
I understand but when you post it in
facebook are you just posting it
organically to the 30 fans you have well
we run the eights exactly good
who are you targeting okay we figure out
who our customers so okay one of one of
the Mitch our customer is the Forex
trader is the what Forex trader okay
because they've run robots yeah okay
then sound server so yeah we target
exactly like they want what that add
other interests are
yep the Forex signal the metatrader4
does kind of thing but how do you have
you have you done influencer marketing
on Instagram since so many of those
Forex people want to build personal
brands that's the next step I'm going to
do after listening what you should
definitely pay for all these characters
that think they're building a personal
brand in Forex mm-hmm and I would do
sponsorships with them as human beings
it's gonna work okay good
alright thank you you got it pass it
over there okay this guy stole it he
broke the rule I've I've actually tried
to contact the raw and the whole team
Gary and of course I know that you're
coming but I volunteered to actually be
the person who bow and to a guy to tow
you around Singapore but I didn't get a
reply similarly to the audience before
the rocks really bad guy ribbon actually
replied me but he said no but it's okay
mice to enter the car and I'm here with
the rent-a-car today so I have a few
questions so I'm actually a content
creator
my name is yen so I've met many
businesses especially in the FMB
industry that still don't understand the
importance of social media I know it's a
simple no-brainer to many people here
but can I ask you know what will you
tell them in a
one minute kind of pitch to tell them
and fall things off let me give you a
good piece of advice thank you never
sell the unsellable what it I would tell
them that it works better than anything
in the world
and then if that took more than a couple
minutes I would go knock on the next
door right the biggest problem is guys
and gals like you and I we get caught up
in trying to convince somebody right
I've never spent a minute trying to
convince somebody of anything we're in a
place where a lot of people still don't
know that this works or they ran one
Facebook ad and it didn't work and now
they decided Facebook doesn't work my
answer is I don't I don't try to
convince people I tell them it works
I tell them millions of businesses have
made it work for them
and then I hope that they're interested
in if you are you trying to get people
as clients yeah good there's unlimited
clients what it so what too many people
do is they dwell and they try to
convince nine clients and that would
have taken up the time for them to ask
for five hundred other people if they
were interested and they would have
landed for clients while they're waiting
to get nine of them to still debate with
them on their fourth meeting trying to
convince them right got it
but it and can I have one more request I
actually bought what I'm gonna jab jab
jab right can I get us a new trip from
you're not right now you can if you pass
it over to that section anybody in that
section sister grandma come for it
correct
awesome hello
go ahead he'll start working good yeah I
have a professional service firm okay
I'm doing a b2b market research I
started in 2013 in Thailand and then I
expanding to Indonesia in 2015
go ahead and now it's time for me to
expand my business again but because I'm
in the professional services when I have
to expand my business I also have to add
head cows and I actually prioritize my
two options for me right now
the first option for me is to expand
into Vietnam okay
and the second option is to your paper
okay
a second option is to start a tech
startup what a tech startup like why is
that your second option because I think
it's a bigger portion ET and if the area
that many clients are for is it's the
pain point and nobody have actually like
looking into that okay if you start the
tech company are you gonna bring in a
tech co-founder yes and give them 50% of
the business no okay so let me tell you
the most fascinating thing when people
decide to go from something linear to
like a tech company they want to do a
tech company and usually they hire
somebody to build the tech because they
don't want to give up any of the equity
this is the number one mistake that
entrepreneurs make when they go into
tech business they hire a firm because
they don't want to give up equity but
when you're in the tech business you're
in the tech business and you better have
a real tech partner and unless your tech
partner has minimum ly 20% up to 50%
they're not gonna care enough and you
also have to understand that they have
the disproportionate leverage because
their tech co-founder in a tech company
you mean if I have to give them by half
of their chairs to make it work I would
tell you that you don't have to but I
have seen an unbelievable amount call it
now maybe five thousand
businesses in the last 10 years that
have gone from I do this but now I'm
gonna do this tech product cuz I see the
pain in my business I'm gonna hire this
little firm to build my app or product
or I'm gonna have a CTO but I'm gonna
pay her or him and I'm not gonna give
them equity and what most people don't
understand when they go into the tech
business and build a tech product
they're at the mercy of the tech tech is
great on paper it's a very different
business when you're actually in it so I
just want to make sure and the reason
I'm going down this path is I want to
make sure that you realize that if
you're going in the tech business you're
gonna lose the leverage unless you're a
developer
does that make sense as a professional
service company is there any option to
the business yes so I think like if
you're gonna build a tech platform
that's a great way to scale the business
I just want to make sure you're going in
eyes wide open that you're going into a
totally different business building a
tech platform in any professional
service is completely different than
being in the professional service
business right having an agency that
builds websites for clients is very
different than starting WordPress so I'm
cool with it as long as you really know
what you're going into and I've just
seen too many people lose their first
business by trying to build a scalable
business when they have no idea what
they're actually going into and I'm just
trying to make sure you wrap your head
around I'm now in the tech business
servicing the professional service
industry that I know well which means
that you do not have the leverage
anymore the architect and executors of
the tech does because what if they build
something for a year or two and then
they leave like it's very important you
get there or you go into another market
right which is more of what you know
other than you have to contextualize the
market that you're now in
both are viable just don't be naive
about the first one because most people
are something in my my for a long time I
wanted to do it so many times and
actually I went to a Master degree in
like big data analytics to learn how to
code so that I could help it helps if
Ashley gave me a very good connection to
the right text I love that I partner
with them okay so let's go back to the
open now that I have that data you're
debating between expansion to a new
market or building the product right and
which and it seems like if you don't
build the product you'll always regret
it yes so let me give you a good piece
of advice I'd rather you be broke than
be regretful I don't want to regret I
just I just want to do it [ __ ] it's like
no matter what like I know like my
choice already go to die building up
text product I already make decision
good I just want to hear like what other
people would think about because why
because it gives a [ __ ] about my opinion
you've already made the decision
yeah but at least you can give me a good
perspective and what I should be I'll
give you a good perspective i 100%
believe in building the tech product
okay you just confirmed my decision
thank you so much
[Applause]
first thing first thank you very much
Gary Vee you really really changed my
life the first time I actually saw your
video was the five minute plea to do yes
prior to that I've been giving myself a
lot of excuses for failing and for not
taking action and for procrastinating
but after I saw that video I when
hundred percent to hundred percent into
just focusing on doing now my question
is as a freelance digital marketer I
faced this challenge of getting a lot of
information and having to keep myself up
to date on what's happening on each and
every one of the platform in order to
deliver a lot of value yes my customers
and so on so how do you actually do that
how do you stay on top of things and yet
deliver value by working a lot so how do
you manage that within 24 hours a day
how do you split your time do you
organize your systemize with Jeffrey not
organized um
I this is the biggest reason I built my
personal brand the number one reason to
stay being a practitioner I don't have
the luxury of reading a headline about
Instagram stories or snapchat filters or
Facebook live without using it because I
have too much to gain on that side so
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy right I
build my brand by being a practitioner
which makes me a better strategist which
makes vaynermedia better and it just
keeps feeding each other so a have you
started building your own profile are
you interested in that or no yes I am
that would be my biggest advice every
time you see something new make sure you
build a profile on everything and then
every time you hear a new feature use it
immediately which will then
systematically make you a very good
strategist you know and then the other
thing I would tell you is don't beat
yourself up you need time for your
family you need vacation time you don't
have to hustle like Gary Vee don't beat
yourself up do the best you can I don't
know everything about everything I
probably know a lot more about a lot of
this stuff than most people but you
don't have to be everything to
everything you
just have to be better than the next
girl do you know what I mean but people
make a huge mistake about is they create
a fake standard in their head the way to
win in business is the same way to be in
to win in sports you just have to be a
little bit faster than the other guy
right I don't have to be 100% on 100% on
everything I just have to be a better
alternative for the same money than
somebody else so I would tell you to be
very and then you got to think about how
much deal flow you have how satisfied
you are I think the biggest thing is
that people beat themselves up they hold
themselves to some fake standard just
make sure you're being reasonable with
yourself alright thank you you're
welcome
how's this work Gary how's it going
super well awesome thanks for being here
so a quick question for you with our
brand we have we run luxury fitness gyms
and beauty clinics and we're fortunate
enough to have a pretty big budget like
our budget for digital marketing is
about a hundred thousand dollars a month
so it allows us to test the log right
yes my question for you is ultimately
like we're trying to drive sales in
revenue right how much how many how much
of the hundred thousand is being done on
bottom of the funnel transactional
membership versus brand are you ready
yes all of it that's the problem so no I
agree with you too that's where I'm
going so I figured we have about like a
cost to revenue KPI of 10% meaning if we
spend 10 grand we make a hundred grand
which is reasonably efficient my
question is we're in agreement our
company that we have to spend more on
top of the funnel and we do have a lot
of Kol is we do have a PR network we
have a celebrity ambassadors and stuff
like that can I give you the answer to
what you're looking for
yes make the 80 cents on the dollar work
like the last hundred cents of dollars
so that you have no risk on the 20 cents
on a dollar to do the high-risk
high-reward
activity that you need to take it to the
next level the answer always in this
situation is taking a step back and
scrutinizing your own ability to go on
the real dr focus dollars to cut 20
cents off the top and make the 80 cents
work like the prior dollar worked and
then then you're basically in no risk
high reward zone and then you cruise so
it's not mindlessly saying okay we're
gonna take this brand work it's about
becoming way better at the thing that
got you here to give you the air cover
to take the risks that will get you to
the next place so what you're saying is
for short-term loss on conversions in
revenue for long term brown building a
more top of the funnel done you're right
no what I'm saying is don't lose any
short-term sales conversion just get 20%
better at that so that you have the 20%
to play with so reallocate the other 20%
once we were able to grow for more top
of the funnel correct take 20 cents on
the dollar and spend 20,000 a month
making a video that is your Dollar Shave
Club that could then take your CAC on
your dr stuff way down because you've
built brand but still make your 80 cents
on the dollar convert at the 10x now has
to be 12x to make what the old numbers
work then there's no pressure from your
CFO your investors or your CEO because
now you've bought yourself the freedom
to take risks because you made the 80
cents act like the former dollar cool
thank you one more question can I get a
selfie with you yep all right here we go
whoever you decide to that was very
inside baseball
hey man hey Gary I'm glad hey glad
thanks so much for being in Singapore
it's awesome to have you here my
question is so you've been spending
quite a bit of time in Asia yes the Hong
Kong Singapore yes so um in your opinion
where does the next wave of media and
tech innovation come from does it come
from
Asia a lot of people say say a lot about
China this will come from the US still
with somewhere else like what do you see
the world going in this respect can I
ask you a question yeah if whatever the
answer is what are you trying to let me
go a little bit hot the answer is from
everywhere and I you know I don't know
like I you know I'm fascinated by the
stardom of entrepreneurship and what it
means for example I'm fascinated with
this dream I keep having that there's
some 13-year old girl in India right now
that so looks up to Elon Musk that she's
gonna do something so crazy and I'm so
pumped about that that's so incredible
right anyway the answer is everywhere
the places that it's conducive to happen
is mainly America mainly manly in China
a little bit of Europe a little bit of
Southeast Asia a tiny bit of South
America so it's gonna be kind of a lot
of the same players because of the
financial impacts the the
entrepreneurial branding within those
ecosystems the macro and micro economic
scenarios there's a lot of different
things that are happening but I think
the more interesting question for me is
why are you asking gotcha um so I guess
for those of us who built our businesses
it's important to know where to focus on
like do you focus on the US market they
focus on the China market yes so those
of us who are employees and have careers
yes where do you build your career
towards - Oh China so look I think
they're two very different if we're
talking about the two kind of
superpowers they're both very different
and both very similar
they have a lot of things going for them
and they have plenty of shortcomings
behind the scenes right and for America
now in front of the scenes right so I
think I think the thing that you need to
debate is what feels more natural to you
as a human what are you more comfortable
with are you more comfortable with an
aging superpower Empire that is more
purebred capitalist but is that maybe
somewhere between the third or fourth
quarter of its you know Empire years or
are you more interested in China which
is in the beginning of its Empire run
but has your name's Vlad you know it's
very hard for guys named Gennady and
Vlad to completely be super comfortable
with any level of communism even if it's
disguised as capitalism right yeah so
you just have to make a decision for
yourself as a human my parents I've
never been back to the Soviet Union
because there's such negative feelings
for what went down there for my family
that I would never
I don't feel even though so I think
China runs its country like most
successful businesses some mix of
capitalism and when needed dictatorship
vaynermedia is far more similar to China
than it is to the United States as far
as the human question you just have to
ask yourself where you'd rather live
both are gonna be just fine by the time
you die Hey how are you thank you I'm
Harry
we're from Louisa we're we're actually a
static company a static static beauty
clinic got it we've been running the
business for four years okay for the
past three years we've been using
traditional market
and what do you see what do you defer
what do you consider traditional
marketing Direct Mail like the world
mouths brochures agents and this year
we're starting to get into digital
marketing and what do you call digital
digital social or Google or banner
programmatic or what we're actually
trying to go into Google YouTube SEO and
social media okay at once right now
we're actually working on it with where
we sell all knowledge about it and I
have these questions for for you I would
like to get us some advice from you on
how can we podcasts our I would think
podcast podcast like any like advice on
the transom podcast and so you want a
podcast why like a video like but why do
you want to do it well we wanted to like
a showcase to our consumer what you're
doing yeah what we're doing and to make
to make them understand better than what
we've been trying to do back then
okay so the first thing is the way
you've been doing marketing
traditionally is far more sales oriented
you've had an agent resale you've done
Pro shores you're doing selling yes a
podcast is the furthest thing from
selling that I know it's over here it's
called branding sellers for four years
or three years hate branding you know
why it costs money up front and nothing
good happens for the first year so first
and foremost I want to make sure that
you know what you're getting yourself
into
which is if you start a podcast it's
going to take up a lot of time it's
gonna cost some money and very little is
going to happen in the first
year so somewhere around nine months
after you start your podcast you two are
gonna look at each other and say Gary
Vee is an [ __ ] as long as you know
that then I'm excited for you to do a
podcast because then over time branding
if you do and execute a good podcast
will have very big effects but before
you jump into podcasts since you've
never even done digital marketing I
don't want you to go too far out
and just do it because I said audios
good I want it I want you to be grounded
in what you're doing and how you're such
a heavy sales organization that I want
to make sure that you know what you're
going in to do I think the sales on
digital can do better than your
brochures 100% do I think the agents
agents are reselling right and referring
yes I would triple down on that because
that's always a good sales engine right
yes they get a piece of the pie but
they're basically a work force right yes
but I would get really good at Facebook
conversion ads and very good at SEO and
as a mainly SEM to be honest more than
SEO but before you begin to really be
committed to podcast now if you've got
the money to do all of it and you're
okay with wasting money and time and
you're one on the podcast to have a
little bit more opportunity in year two
then that's great but you have to be
smart and think about it from a
practical standpoint not an idealist
ideological standpoint sure well we're
trying to have figure out our budget
into digital marketing into as much as
you can afford as much as we can afford
should we span it equally in Google you
should spend 50% of it upfront tasting
everything and then double down on
what's working okay so if you're gonna
spend a hundred thousand spend fifty
thousand in the first three four months
try a lot of different things and become
good at understanding what's happened
and then double down do you think it's
recommended if we use YouTube as a
channel to do the conversion rate do you
think it's possible using YouTube for
convert sure I mean of course but it's
difficult now there is a product that
you should look at there's a way to
target people with a YouTube pre-roll
video that is based on what they
searched on Google I think it's an
incredible product for all of you Google
YouTube has a pre-roll video product
that you can target against what people
are searching for on Google sodas you
can imagine if I'm searching on Google
how to drink wine or wine things even if
I go to youtube and watch Jets football
videos it's gonna service me wine ads up
front if somebody's on google searching
beauty or spas or the words you know
your video even if they're watching
kitten videos on YouTube being a
pre-roll is gonna convert better this is
what I mean about being a practitioner
versus a headline reader got to know
these nuances to be successful can I
have a last request we would like to
have a wee fee is it possible a what a
wee fee oh we feel like we in a selfie
yes okay that sounds cool bring the
bring the bring the mic up oh you can
ask a question then I'm gonna have you
bring it up anybody over there walk away
okay go ahead hey yeah we could do it
now yeah okay so first thing that I want
to say is like a big thank you thank you
for everything that I've been doing the
content that we're putting out so
inspirational that the first thing to
express on this exchange is gratitude
thank you brother what's your name my
name is eka I'm from Brazil based here
in Singapore I'm listening okay so we
start up here in Singapore okay b2b okay
focus on the literary market and
as you may know like VR so in the early
stages and we don't have it even like in
the word on us like big so Sasuke's like
nerd scale that can make like sales a
little bit like challenging if you're
doing like we're doing well we just want
to see if you have any sorry I do I have
some real thoughts on b2b VR okay I'm
very much a big fan of you tying your
business very close to experiential and
event marketing the place where you can
find budget is when brands and
businesses are activating in real life
at big events where VR experiences are
the draw for them to get people to come
to their booth or their exposition or
there it is the only place that I think
is really viable in a in a b2b
environment for VR so that's where we're
going because like we sound like boats
yachts so the the big elected point is
uh
boat shows so there's like a place for
us like to so be trying we've been like
can you reflect it or to be a little
more creative as well just high luxury
high affluent areas where you can do
activations Art Basel is a place where a
brand or company may want to activate a
VR yacht experience just because of the
rich people that are running around so
you should map the hundred biggest rich
people events and then reach out to the
people that have exhibited there in the
past and see if they want a hook to draw
people in okay whenever we're talking to
the shipbuilders for instance right so
one of the the challenges lecture to
express order VR cases because like for
them is like I think like is completely
new right yes it's difficult for us like
to see to prove like our or pitch right
any ideas how can we bring like those
guys on board even though we don't have
like other cases us or you mean they're
looking for case studies of other people
that did it yeah I mean this has been my
whole career the answer is you don't
have them you know same answer I gave
that nice uber driver as soon as they
say I need a case study to move forward
they're not in the VR
business got it mixes make a big list
when you're selling the future the
answer is always make a big list cuz
you're gonna get a lot more nose than
yeses okay thanks so much
just listening you have the Vayner betta
yes our program can you share a little
bit more about it twenty-five thousand
dollars a month for us to do the
marketing for small businesses and it's
a very watered down version of what
vaynermedia does for the biggest brands
okay but it finally got to a place where
I believed enough in it to actually sell
it so I think it's ry+ in a $300,000
macro for small and medium-sized
businesses but obviously not that small
three hundred thousand dollars for
content and distribution in social
networks is for a business doing some
real revenue can you give me the mic yep
Gary Gary yeah I have more minutes oh
you have what five more money good this
well here give it to me because I want
to get it yep
yep nice or if you would like to take it
longer it's okay sub-dean very happy
speaking of that product there is a lot
of for me out on social media there's a
lot of sorry I [ __ ] hate public
speaking about clear nobody's judging so
there's a lot of [ __ ] that I see on
social media it just seems like people
are just churning and churning and
churning content you can see the reason
why people are hiring you for that
product when would you advise people to
kind of step back and hone their skills
and shop in the soul this is just like
take it and it was a big thing that
everyone said today is take action take
action take action but there's obviously
your time so yeah yeah let's make it a
little bit more selfish for you what do
you try to figure out all right so I was
I'm transitioning recently from
I was in the fitness space I was a
fitness influencer I was like one of the
in the UK amongst the first kind of
young people to get really big yep
and that kind of took off on Instagram
on Twitter I then got sick of that
industry yes and transitioned into the
content space so Tom and media awesome
previously I just a prerequisite that I
created a business like an app for
discounts a niche discount app in the UK
and it blew up awesome got bored of that
so I got bored a fitness got bored of
the app transitioning and I kind of I'm
at the point where I'm like right now I
get a bit like 4 at 4 a.m. every day I'm
like study in film I'm sitting in media
and everyone around me is just like
artist create create create but to me
I'm like this is a time for me to
sharpen my saw and get my content to a
level where it can actually gain
attention I like it I just want to know
when when you have done that because you
pull back in your content for you for
eight years when are you deciding to
pull back and learns and then to execute
for me based on the content I'm putting
out it's when I feel like there's
something really meaningful to talk
about that I want to get louder right
like I talked about earlier for you it
sounds like you're doing original
creative I'm asking yeah it's more like
nonfiction
yeah nonfiction to me then it would be
when you feel it's ready right I don't
think you're now what I will say is
don't be scared to put a little bit out
there remember how I talked did or I did
that in an interview I didn't say it on
stage yet nobody remembers your losses
George Lucas had movies before Star Wars
you know so I wouldn't be super duper
scared of putting some stuff out there
we're not gonna judge that was crappy
now you can't win on the next thing the
other thing is you could be very
thoughtful and put out little pieces of
content that are parts of
story Tim Ferriss sold 4-hour workweek
because he used Google and tested six
different titles or four I don't
remember the story but he saw consumers
intent around that title and it really
worked I see a lot of the same happening
and regional content online you can run
really smart [ __ ] I would create a fake
Facebook page some other brand that's
not going to be your coming-out party
put some content there run fifty dollars
worth of ads against the demo you think
you're reaching and look at the
qualitative and qualitative feedback it
might give you some insight if the sword
is sharp enough to take out of the shed
see what I mean I think there's a way
for you to use it as offence instead of
looking at as detrimental because to
your point and it's using your own words
there's so much being put out now that
people are forgetting you know like our
attention span is so zero there's very
little damage you can do to the IP
compared to the way it plays out in your
head I always told my friends nobody
really gives a [ __ ]
you know you do because it's your baby
it's why I put out so much content I
think it's all good enough and if it's
not the greatest thing for the world
that's okay I learned from it I'm
putting it out there right for me I want
to get it out there but you know I think
you should use it as an office how are
you I'm good thank you Michael from
Perth in Australia three of us came out
Nowell grew up in the wine business been
there plenty of times I know it well
this one's a little bit off off Tories a
little bit over the last year so I've
been going down a bit of a philosophical
Road thinking about life it could be a
midlife thing I don't know and I noticed
that you I think you're probably one of
the great philosophers of our modern age
I think from a way from branding away
from marketing and I've loved your
content with like Ryan holiday and
and stuff like that I'm wondering if at
some stage you may write a book away
from as I said the marketing and social
media stuff more about sort of a few
life lessons like the the famous three
words you're gonna die that sort of
stuff
yeah good I'll buy it I think yes and I
think you clearly kind of see what's
going on I think I look I'm writing a
book called perfectly parented it's a
parenting book you're right you're right
I am writing that I uh I think I'm doing
some pretty hardcore philosophies and
then blending it down into a little bit
more tactical and subject matter I think
I'm gonna evolve right like I think even
if you look at early Wine Library TV i
I'm starting to throw life lessons into
the it's a wine show and I was doing it
right now I'm into this marketing thing
but my intuition is yes yeah that's
correct thing like five hundred years
from now whenever I think you'll be
remembered as a philosopher more than a
marketer I think you know I think my ego
is very happy with you right now but I'm
ego is the enemy but but i but I would
tell you that it's how I think of myself
much more I think my stuff is very heady
philosophical what saved me from being
too heady is my love of execution and I
think I've forced myself lower down the
funnel of my philosophies to make them
tangible and useful but yeah I think I
have heavy themes in that world which is
why it feels native to you and I do
think that the people that if you listen
carefully to even today people are
getting a lot more value out of my
structure of thinking then I gave you
some tidbit you know I love when people
like Gary Vee you suck you know that I
love this is my favorite why don't you
give us like an actual piece of advice
enough of this hustle and go and lalala
and I always laugh I'm like dude and I
reply cuz I love it I'm like dude google
it
you can google anything tangible you
want to learn how to use hashtags you
want to learn how to edit YouTube videos
you want to learn how to create snapchat
filters you don't need a guru to sell
you an $80 ebook it's free it's called
google.com to me I think the stuff we
talk about philosophical is imperative
because it becomes your life's strategy
which then dictates your activities like
him not being impatient and going wide
is disproportionately more valuable for
his business than me telling him to use
you know read in a post on LinkedIn that
will convert you know 1% higher that
matters to but nowhere close to the
stuff we were talking about earlier so I
appreciate it you're gonna die it's a
very hard one to explain to the kids
sometimes that it's it's powerful right
it's I don't know what everybody here is
thinking the reason that lovely lady in
the back with the tech product right I'd
rather her fail on her tech product than
regret never doing it because the regret
is gonna eat her alive and that's why I
think about you're gonna die like I
don't know what you guys are thinking
but whatever the hell you want to do I
highly recommend you do it because if
you spend time with old people like I do
you will figure out real fast it is your
biggest vulnerability it will be the
thing that kills you when you can't do
anything about it regret is scary it's
as scary as it gets it is okay to get a
crew kind of selfie with the three of us
and yourself sure cool one more we
donors
hi Gary how are you I'm fine
I'm Jack from Texas to Asia so we
actually very passionate on education so
I would like to get your view how do you
see we can evolve the education from now
to it's to brief you sure you got it so
one more time the education is what one
more time how do we evolve the education
which education what kind of education
higher education higher education yeah
so I think higher education is in a very
vulnerable place because I think most
people in higher education don't
understand that the only thing they're
trading on is brand and as we start
seeing the biggest and best universities
in the world start creating these
products that are diluting their brand
right which we're seeing a lot of now
Stanford and Harvard selling courses
where people can say I'm LinkedIn they
went there even though they took a
course I think the way higher education
is going to evolve is the professor's
themselves are gonna start getting huge
leverage to go direct to consumer ok
start trading in that way so I think you
know if you have if you have passion for
the institution okay versus the actual
education the money making entity known
as a university well then I would change
the business model very quickly because
it's got a real vulnerability over the
next decade because of the
decentralization of information right
yeah so I guess my question is is your
passion lie in the university itself
being successful or education itself
being successful it's actually the
hundred years old education system we
like want to make a change even we are
small yeah
for what purpose I just feel that the
youth or the Millennial they just
somehow need some guidance along the way
to actually discover what they desire
and you feel that modern universities
and its
tuitions are good at that no right so so
do you think it has anything to do with
the financial benefits of being a
university because that's the question
right I I think we all agree that this
notion that four years at university is
becoming this amazing guiding light for
Millennials to find what they're
passionate about has a hundred years of
being proven to not be true yes
so my question becomes with higher
education is what's the purpose
I default into the purpose is to make
money which is not in the vested
interest of the user okay which is a
vulnerable model if your passion is to
help young people find their passions
yes I have a funny feeling your default
wouldn't be into saving the
institution's known as universities okay
now that's the interesting to be right I
feel that unfortunately universities
have manifested into incredibly
self-serving machines yeah and they're
so broken that I've gone so on the other
side and I can't speak to other parts of
the world but in America they've become
the worst thing on earth kids are
getting unbelievable amounts of debt
that they can't get out of and aren't
being put in a position to recoup it
within the first 20 years of them being
out of it
now I know there's other rules and other
places so I know a lot of us are from
different places but if you're if you're
telling me your passion is to help kids
find their passions I would use a blank
piece of paper and reinvent a new model
I have a funny feeling that whatever you
come up with is not gonna be something
that the traditional universities are
gonna like because it's gonna break
their financial system yes as equity so
now the question is do you want to find
a new business model for a traditional
institution because that's what you do
for a living right now or do you want to
go on a quest to Riaan
and the opportunity those are two very
different things quest to reinvent good
so I'm I'm an investor and a startup
called mission you okay which is a
different business model where they
educate right and in for free okay but
in return the students give fifteen
percent of their salary the first three
years of their career okay I think what
Adams doing there is trying to rethink
the way this is all played out yeah but
I still think it's self-serving interest
right produce people that you know if
you think about that model produce
people that will actually make money
yeah so that I can get back my 15% you
know I questioned the whole thing now I
questioned the whole thing because I was
a terrible student
I was super self-aware of who I was I
would tell you if you really want to
achieve your goal you need to create a
model that gets to six to ten year olds
and you start finding a way to teach
self-awareness okay if you can figure
that out you will achieve your goal okay
thank you Gary you're welcome I'll go
more okay okay but you know maybe you
know this you stand here until tomorrow
and just leave and then you know no all
these guys want to have a picture with
you yeah but if you're in charge not me
I'm okay so do your job so which one do
you want me to do okay good hi okay
in every businesses there's the supply
and the demand side the most interesting
thing that I've heard that he's saying a
long time because you're a hundred
percent right and it blows my mind that
almost nobody talks about it okay so
here's my issue I don't have any problem
with the demand portion okay okay the
minute I go out there I open my mouth
I'll get I'll get the business you don't
know how to fill the pipe yes and I
don't know how to duplicate myself
because you can't I can't I don't know
if you heard
yes I know that but I need to I really
really need to automate by business you
have a duplicate myself so that I can go
home and have a holiday I understand so
what there's only two things holding you
back your inability to operate or your
ego so we just have to dissect it with a
couple questions what do you sell I'm in
consulting great why haven't you hired
more people to consult I have good but
they're just not up to it this is not up
to the level and up to whose level yours
or the clients the level that I set as a
basis to benchmark ask what I got for a
spot as my service so so you real quick
who's hiring these people me okay
so let's play this game together all
right what's what's about to happen is
you're about to get exposed to yourself
and then you'll be able to win you're
playing a very fun game of you've got a
big [ __ ] ego I mean it you've got to
wrap your head around this you're hiring
you've created an arbitrary benchmark
that nobody's hitting because you have
put yourself on a pedestal at the mercy
and the detriment of building a bigger
business because you want to sell
fulfill that you're so much better play
with me you can't think about what you
stand so don't don't scale then be a
one-woman shop I believe I can do more I
believe we should duplicate this I mean
I've got the models I've got everything
there I'm basically template that
everything that I do so all you need to
do is take the template follow the SOP
and let's go out hit the market how many
employees have you had at the height 12
and how many do you have now
two
and was a customer's firing or that mean
you and at one point Yoli this year
everyone left and I'm fine with that why
because they realize that it was the
wrong place for them to be and I
realized that I can't
that's no point for me to keep anyone
when they can't do the job and I'm I'm
prepared have more there have you
thought about the possibility of you
being a great consultant but a terrible
boss I'm asking I'm asking I have that
repetition I know okay so thanks for
answering look I think you have I'm
being serious with you and the reason I
went right at it I want you to win it's
a game of ego what people don't
understand is that is the problem for
all the the reason I've been able to
scale vaynermedia many think that I have
an ego I play on confidence which is
what allows me to scale because I don't
hold everybody to an arbitrary metric
that has no reality other than what's
playing in my own head to me you've
you're if you're the one firing or
they're quitting cuz the work
environment is exhausting because you
keep pounding the drum of some fake
Mendoza line of quality needed that you
are the judge and jury of and it's some
interpretation of how you decide they
follow the template you're just
scratching your own ego of how great you
are at the detriment of your business
the reason I have 800 employees and high
retention is I don't hold any of them to
my standard because they don't need to
be me to build an actual business you
need to decide if you want to build a
one-woman shop or an actual business
and can I tell you something there's
nothing wrong with the one-woman shop
the way you'll scale is you may charge
for content you may write a book you may
start getting paid more to speak you
don't maybe you don't you know what I
mean and and what even when I say it
when I see you react you don't need to
build a 40-person consulting shop
because maybe you don't like it it's not
that you're a bad person it's that you
don't want to lower your standards and
if you're stuck in that well then
monetize a different way by expanding a
more around you versus trying to build
out an actual business around it do you
know what I mean and that's okay doesn't
make you a bad person as a matter of
fact you'll probably be
disproportionately more successful
because you're being self-aware and
enjoying being the one person band and
making your money that way you don't
have to build vaynermedia you don't have
to build being a McKinsey you and be
your best self your way and enjoy it how
are you I am doing great my name is
racin and I'm actually a psychiatrist in
practice and also a founder of this
brand called legacy because ragga C
means recent legacy so I want to create
my own legacy okay so now now that now
that I'm actually in doing freelance
coaching training and speaking
motivational speaking
I would like to actually ask you if you
were me within the next two to three
years because I plan to leave nursing
because I find that I have a lot of
potential and I believe I can do even
more
not just helping the mentally ill and
even my mother who suffers from
schizophrenia I want to help people
around and impact lives as well inspire
them what would you as she suggests or
what will you do
you are in my position and you want to
leave in two or three years yes I would
save money save money save money okay
and produce content to create awareness
for when you leave and I wouldn't spend
money on dumb stuff because when you go
make that jump you want to be in the
most safe place financially right so I
would save money and produce content I
have been producing content which is
what I call the raggedy show so the
record show is actually where I
interview entrepreneurs successful
entrepreneurs actors even even just now
I actually interviewed shared as well
and I interview a lot of people I
already have done only 11 episodes for
now but I am doing more because I'm
actually using Facebook life to do it
because I feel that Facebook life has
always been a negative component where
people actually use it to see people
jumping down or accidents and stuff like
that
so I want to use it as a value adding
content so I use it and then after that
I convert it to YouTube and then I will
share it on YouTube and let people watch
as well okay yeah so this this is the
thing that I'm doing and one thing is I
want to actually scale it up I want to
have more people to watch it I want to
have more viewers and there's two things
you have to do make more shows okay and
be more interesting okay because don't
forget you're doing something very
interesting to me you said that you have
the potential to be very motivational
that you want to help people this that
the other thing but then your first
execution and media is to trade off
other people's equity it's an insight
there's nothing wrong with it no
different than the last conversation we
have there's nothing wrong with anything
if you have good intent but you have to
be thoughtful and ask yourself if you
have so much potential to be so
motivational and bring value why did you
go down the path
of having guests which is always the
quickest tell to needing something else
to drive content versus just being on
yourself and up here and it's important
for you to be honest with yourself maybe
you're trying to get your legs
underneath you there's nothing wrong
with it but the way you framed it up
where you converted your name into
legacy and your first move is to
interview other people which is the real
driver of it you have the first thing I
would say is do not jump until you're
ready at a place where you can command
an audience by yourself without
leveraging somebody else the reason I
knew that I was gonna win in business
content in podcast was 99% of podcasts
were people interviewing other people
which means the host is the commodity
and the guest is the draw there's so
many subtleties and everything that
we're doing here you got to look for
them because they're really interesting
tells to what's really going on right
like the last wonderful lady next to you
that I'm excited to me that's gonna be
the thing I think about on the fly no
mic I think she's gonna win
you have to get to that place when you
realize if you're the one making the
rules and nobody can hit it that needs
to be thought about what does that mean
same for you if you're gonna make that
jump especially when you have the
audacity to convert your name into
legacy that you need to be good enough
before you jump into not being at the
mercy of somebody else sure thank you
last one yo-yo I just want to get as
close as possible because I still can't
believe I'm talking to you thank you
okay and this is the last question guys
sure I got you here you talk a lot about
self we're gonna go for legacy you're
gonna have to learn how to take selfies
just can't you're looking awesome thank
you my friend good luck to you yes sir
Gary among all the things that you
talked about being branding marketing
and all of that the thing which hits me
hard the most is self-awareness because
we always talk about self-awareness and
the reason why that so it's because I've
got a brother who is born with cerebral
palsy
yes he's born with cerebral palsy he was
a breech baby and doctors said that he
wouldn't be able to live for more than
24 hours yes and but then he's gone on
he's achieved some good things he's even
written a book that's titled better than
normal it's the t-shirt that I'm wearing
and he wants to become a speaker yes he
wants to be he want to go on and inspire
life our mission is to our dream is to
inspire 50 million people by 2050 and
coming to the question do you think
because you are you're super successful
you're super successful entrepreneur
everything that you are we all want to
be you I want to be you do you think you
would have been this successful if you
were born with some kind of disability
or if you were born I know you had some
disadvantages in your life but do you
think you would have been this
successful if you were born with a
disability something that you cannot
change about yourselves on Hydro
physical I don't know I think it would
be crazy for me to answer that question
here's what I would say I think that
disadvantages are the ultimate advantage
I think adversity is a humongous
advantage in life but when you go into
real diseases or things that could
create huge insecurities if you're born
without an eye as a child like having a
glass eye could have created such a
complex that maybe the confidence would
have never been there so I think it's
crazy for me to even take a stab at
judging what would have been I think
that would be inappropriate and the
reason why I say that because although
our our brand is better than normal if
you ask his age he's not here today
because he's in India doing his therapy
and we are doing a movement in India
because the market is bigger but he's
got to do therapy every single day six
to eight hours of it just to mean
just to maintain his state and if you
ask his age even though we want to
inspire 50 million people by 2050 to
become better than normal if you ask him
it takes before you die what is the one
thing that you want
the irony of Edith is that he will tell
you that he wants to be normal
of course because that's his truth you
know instead of some arbitrary number of
50 I mean 50 million people 2050 is an
arbitrary thing that you guys stumbled
on that has zero anything I think that
you know to me I've always thought about
it is best way to get to 50 million is
to focus at one at a time the second I
hear of 20 50 50 I'm like finished
finished right like so that makes sense
and I think you know it's super awesome
to see the love you have for your
brother
I think a couple things you need to do
me one favor a have no interest in being
me
B have no interest in wrapping yourself
up in your brothers story because you're
just gonna end up resentful and you need
to ironically started with
self-awareness you need to go inside
yourself and really figure out what
you're doing here are you how much are
you using this for your own want how
much are you doing this for him like you
need to get the way you've structured
all this this could get real bad real
fast and so I want you to promise me to
just be thoughtful because a lot of
times it's the same way I see like I
spend a lot of time in this dynamic you
need to be careful my my main purpose in
my life I feel is I want him to be
independent physically emotionally
mentally that's what that's what I
really want regardless of the brand
regardless of the very we make any money
I want him to be independent if that's
your number one yeah that's my number
one then that has nothing to do with the
way your positioning everything that
you're talking about
there's nothing you've said that even
comes remotely to mapping to that truth
I want him to know that I don't think he
knows that that that's my number one so
go tell him I told him that a million
time but he see somehow believes that
it's not my responsibility for him
to be independent that would make sense
you need to be thoughtful promise me
because this scenario turns out bad a
lot you end up with nothing
now your brother not the brand just be
smart and I know you don't read a lot of
books and you probably read only four
books in your life but I would just like
to give this one to you maybe for your
kids maybe some time and you have thank
you so much you're welcome thank you
very much guys thank you Gary put your
hands together for Gary Vaynerchuk
ladies and gentlemen thank you oh cool
cool as Marcus cruise astok would say
great a great character at vaynermedia
anyway nonetheless I hope that went well
for you and would you love would love
your comment below of your favorite
question from the queue not your
favorite thing that I said or or the
thing you learned but your favorite
question and why from this keynote see
[Music]